nevada state college is one of the
fastest growing schools in the country
it's expanded through its 20 years
despite almost closing back during the
recession well with that growth of
course comes more expansion mary jane
bellies joining us live in henderson
with what students can expect when they
head back to class a little over a week
john and heather you know nevada state
college students its faculty and staff
have worked closely with its planning
team as well as the community and the
city of henderson to create a
development plan for the campus for the
near and long time future nevada state
college's president says the goal is to
have a little bit more than 20 000
students on campus in the next few years
new improvements are designed to meet
the needs of students and access to a
number of different subjects this
includes a new education building and a
busy residence facility at nevada state
college there's a little over 500 acres
some yet to be developed and those ideas
will be discussed in the upcoming
legislative session
our christensen education building which
is the first a building that was i think
actually uh funded significantly by the
state within the last decade it allows
us we had to raise money for that but we
had private donors but we also had state
contributions to that and it took
over a decade to get that building here
so our hope is that over the next
several years the state will continue to
make those investments
pollard says the new improvements are
centered around the needs for students
like efforts that went into their
library system to provide resources
saving students a lot of money and other
developments pollard hopes to include is
a athletics facility and more
partnerships to drive economic
developments to the college reporting
live in henderson mary jane vallieza
live local now